bonsoir à tous
alors définitivement ce soir on va
terminer de rentrer dans une nouvelle
ère puisque je vais vous parler de la
blue jam alors là blocs shy'm vous en
avez peut-être entendu parler si je vous
cite par exemple
bitcoin alors bitcoin on sait pas bien
ce que c'est c'est une bonne chère une
crypto bonnet enfin bref
peut-être que certains d'entre vous en
ont encore plus entendu parler avec
facebook quand le monde a sorti une
alerte il ya quelques mois en annonçant
que facebook lancé sa crypte aux
monnaies libres a alors derrière tout ça
on va revenir à des choses très basiques
d'accord la bloque shine avant tout
c'est une technologie une technologie
qui permet de transmettre et de stocker
des informations de manière sécurisée
transparente et sans aux organes de
contrôle retenez surtout ça sans organes
de contrôle alors on peut utiliser la
blog shane de manière très simple
d'abord pour tracer quand je parle de
tracé je parle de traçabilité
prenez les scandales sanitaires qui
existent les laits infantiles avec de la
salmonelle ou encore des problématiques
de contrefaçon on pourra utiliser cette
technologie blocs chaîne avec un
registre public distribué pour vérifier
la bonne application de diverses
techniques dans une chaîne de production
un deuxième usage de la blog shane ce
concerne l'utilisation des smart
contracte le smart contrat que ça veut
dire contrat intelligent on pourrait
donc mettre en place une technologie
blog shane pour que des contrats
s'exécute de manière spontanée
une fois que les divers éléments se
rencontrent mais ce qui nous intéresse
véritablement ce soir c'est ce que l'on
appelle le digital cache la crypto
monnaie alors la crypto monnaie ce n'est
ni plus ni moins qu'une implication
possible de la blog shane
il ne faut pas confondre en permanence
blog shane et crypto monnaie la bloque
chaînes existent seul bel et bien sans
l'utilisation d'une crypte aux monnaies
alors pour faire simple une crypto
monnaie on va retourner en arrière avec
les monnaies l'eau
al je vais prendre un exemple dans la
région annécienne en haute savoie on à
la gentiane contre quelques euros on
peut avoir dans sa poche de la gentiane
et on peut aller acheter dans des
commerces qui sont validées son café
prendre un journal et cetera et c est
bien les crypto monnaie c'est la même
chose sauf que vous vous en doutez on ne
se limite pas au bassin annécien mais on
se connecte dans le monde entier et
c'est peut-être ça qui effraie
aujourd'hui le gouvernement les
institutions bancaires c'est cette
connexion au monde
on en a parlé ça a été l'objet de toute
la soirée l'inter nationalité
l'internationalisation la globalisation
et bien c'est ça plus sage des crypto
monnaie une des monnaies les plus connus
étant forcément le bitcoin puisque c'est
la naissance même de la blocs chaîne et
on passe si vous voulez d'un système
institutionnel bien précis avec des
états je vous signale que les états sont
là normalement pour battre monnaie un
système bancaire traditionnel
les banques centrales avec notamment
nous en europe la banque centrale
européenne pour la zone euro un nouveau
monde un monde des gaffes à qu'on a déjà
évoqué et c'est là que les choses vont
commencer un petit peu à être plus
complexe tant qu'on reste avec la
gentiane à annecy globalement les choses
se passent bien
six autres demain facebook lance sa
monnaie on pourra donc faire des
transactions directement depuis son
smartphone en utilisant libre à la
crypte monnaie de facebook on pourra
également utiliser via instagram
on pourra aussi l'utiliser via whatsapp
on peut également songé à amazon
si amazon lance sa crypte au bonnet je
pourrais directement et très facilement
dans ces cas-là dépenser mon digital
cash sur amazon vous vous doutez bien
que quand on se limite à annecy et à la
gentiane l'impact économique est très
limité quand par contre on parle de
facebook par le télégramme on parle d'
amazon
là les choses deviennent plus graves
alors on y voit certains avantages
on peut
voir notamment un avantage on va plus
vite c'est plus rapide
il y a moins de frais vous avez tous
essayé de transférer de l'argent à
l'étranger
je vous parle même pas en euros je parle
dans une autre monnaie si vous souhaitez
par exemple envoyer de l'argent à l'île
maurice
je vous prie de croire que les choses
sont assez complexes il faut passer par
votre banque qui va émettre un virement
ça va ensuite être vérifiée il va ya
voir l'application d'un taux de change
etc etc etc
ça va prendre plusieurs jours là en
quelques secondes je peut transférer de
l'argent de manière immédiate sécurisé
et transparente cryptée et fiable avec
un registre qui va stocker cette
information ça ce sont les avantages il
ya bien évidemment des inconvénients
l'inconvénient majeur en tout cas pour
les gouvernements c'est le problème de
la fiscalité
si j'achète si je transfère quid de la
fiscalité quid de la tva
quid des impôts comment ça se passe qui
va récupérer les taxes
comment je vais pouvoir m'assurer que
les personnes vont véritablement les
payer et en quelle mollet est ce que je
vais faire une opération de conversion
est ce que je vais devoir mettre ensuite
l'argent que j'ai récupéré en dollars
quid de la plus value toutes ces
questions-là intéresse bien évidemment
les gouvernements et puis on songe assez
vite au blanchiment d'argent au
financement du terrorisme aux personnes
qui lie à derrière ces crypto monnaie on
a souvent évoqué les crypto monnaie et
le darknet c'est une réalité
le nier serait passer à côté d'une
partie du système et d'une partie
aujourd'hui des enjeux qui concernent la
bloque chaînes et des crypto monnaie
alors les états ne sont pas restés
indifférents et la france il faut bien
l'avouer c'est bien positionnée sur le
sujet depuis l'avènement de la loi pacte
nous avons pu mettre en place au sein du
système français des mécanismes
juridiques qui permettent en tout cas de
se poser les bonnes questions il est
trop tôt pour avoir aujourd'hui les
résultats mais je vais vous donner deux
exemples précis que la loi pacte encadre
désormais premièrement les levées de
fonds en crypto monnaie imaginez pour un
porteur de projet le renouveau du croix
ding avant quand on souhaitait récolter
de l'argent on faisait appel à des
business angels on mettait en place tout
un mécanisme mais on ne touchait pas le
monde entier on touchait déjà sa famille
ses amis
peut-être certains partenaires dans
l'état français mais on ne pouvait pas
aller dans le monde entier grâce aux
cryptes monnaie il est très facile
aujourd'hui de créer un site internet de
lancer une opération de financement ce
qu'on appelle les haïtiens et d'avoir
des investisseurs de tous bords débarqué
en mettant en place via quelques
transferts d'argent ce qu'on appelle il
ya des bouts allaitent
on peut récupérer beaucoup d'argent la
france a décidé que pour mettre en place
une opération pareille
il fallait se soumettre à un cahier des
charges bien précis et la mf l'autorité
des marchés financiers veille à ce que
les gens qui soient sains et cohérent
conscient des enjeux puisse
véritablement obtenir un visa
un label optionnel alors vous allez me
dire c'est optionnel
c'est comme ça en tout cas si on
n'obtient pas ce visa il se peut que
l'on soit blacklisté par le régulateur
français
et puis vous vous en doutez l'univers de
la blog shane des crypto monnaie tout
autour de ça il y à ce que l'on appelle
un écosystème et des services provider
des prestataires de services qui
débarque de tous les horizons et qui
nous promettent de pouvoir conserver nos
petits portefeuilles de crypto monnaie
qui nous promettent également de pouvoir
convertir nos bitcoin en euros en
dollars etc
toutes ces entreprises là si elle
souhaite exercer sur le sol français
elles vont devoir être à minima
enregistrés auprès de notre régulateurs
voire même obtenir un agrément
donc vous voyez que l'état français a
souhaité n'ont pas sanctionné et
interdire l'usagé de la bloque ce n'est
des crypto monnaie mais a quand même
voulu imposer un cadre législatif
sauf que je voulais dit en introduction
nous parlons véritablement d'un système
sans organes de contrôle alors la france
s'est positionné en europe nous avons
également la république de malte qui se
revendent
être là blog shane island et puis si on
est passé les frontières de l'ue est
emballé en suisse où effectivement nous
avons également un autre team
législation qui semble plus ou moins
adaptés et puis encore plus loin nous
avons à singapour et puis nous avons
aussi les états unis qui se posent des
questions
sauf que croyez moi la situation telle
qu'elle se présente aujourd'hui on ne
peut pas avoir une solution franco
française
on ne peut pas avoir une solution franco
maltaise on ne peut pas avoir une
solution franco singapourienne tout cela
n'a pas de sens puisque la technologie
dépasse véritablement les frontières il
faut donc les gouvernements que les
grandes
les grandes or les grands organes
institutionnels se rencontrent à l'hymne
des réunions trouve des solutions
mais tout ça ça prend du temps et j'ai
envie de vous dire nous allons parler ce
soir de deux technologies de personnes
où tout va vite
tout se passe vite nous on veut toujours
aller plus loin faire mieux faire plus
vite il faut dépenser le moins d'argent
possible avec le plus de rapidité et
d'efficacité
et bien pour trouver une solution à la
réglementation pour pouvoir
véritablement trouver un consensus qui
soit tout à la fois économiques
monétaires financiers mais aussi
sociétal il va falloir du temps et ce
n'est pas dans l'air du temps de dire
qu'il faut du temps mais je vous le dis
pour des sujets aussi éloquent grand et
inventif de tout ce qui a été débattue
ce soir il va nous falloir encore un
petit peu de temps
[Applaudissements]